Well, Brady, we'll talk about the number of particles in the universe
We will calculate the number of particles in the visible universe
So this is, as you know, the part of the universe that we can see
Where light can be reached from us
What particles are we talking about here?
So we will be interested in the particles that are particles that we are aware of
Which is essential, we are interested in which has a block
So, we're not talking about photons, for example
What we are going to talk about is things like quarks, electrons, and things
So quarks, of course, will live within protons and neutrons
The electrons will be in orbit around those protons and neutrons in the atoms
Pretty much everything else is unimportant
How do we do this? So we will use four units of data
Part of which would be cosmological data
Data from the Blanc satellite, which measures cosmic microwave radiation
Scientists call it the radiation left by the Big Bang
As you know, it's the radiation you get when the first type of neutral atoms starts to form
So, we'll use data from that
We will use a little bit of particle physics data, as well
So these are the four parts of the information that we will use
So the first of these elements is the critical density of the universe
So this is a good measure of what energy density is in the universe
This is because we know that the universe is very close to being spatially flat
So it's not a ball or a horse
It's somewhere between the two
Because of this, we know that its density is very close
Of the critical density, which is actually an actual density in fact
If you look at it, compare it with water density
Water density is one gram per cubic centimeter
This is a million million million times less, right?
So, it's pretty cool, right? Because this is the universe we are talking about
The next part of the information we will need
Represents a fraction of the budget of that energy in the universe
Stored in barions. Now, why are barions?
Well, the barions, in this context, are just
Protons and neutrons, is the place where quarks live
The other thing the size of the universe can be observed. Again, the data coming from Blanc
We get this number from about 10 to twenty-eight centimeters
One with twenty-eight zeros thereafter
So, many centimeters, but the universe is big, right?
Brady: "Why is it in the centimeter?
Well, you put it in the centimeter, because it was a centimeter, and I do not want to start
All my modules are corrupted. So I thought it was safe to keep a bunch of units there
The last thing is that I will need a proton block
The barions we are concerned with are protons and neutrons
They have the same mass, very close, you know, the cluster is largely identical
Thus the mass of the proton is ten to minus twenty-four grams, approx
These are the four things we will need to work, as you know
How many particles are in the universe
So, let's start, we will determine the number of barions in the universe
In other words, how many protons and neutrons, in total, are there
The first thing we will do to calculate that is that we will say
What is the energy density stored in barions?
Or stored in protons and neutrons?
Well, that's just a part of the barions
Fold the total density. This gives us the energy density stored in the barions
Want to know the total energy, so the total mass stored in the barium
We need to double the size of the universe
But we know how big the universe is, right?
They are given through this radius. If the size is the size of the ball
Only for this radius, which is four, pi to three, and then radius
This gives us the total energy stored in the barions
Well, these barions, as we said, are essentially protons and neutrons, essentially the same mass
Therefore if you want to know the number of existing barions
We just divide the block on one barion, okay?
So we divide the proton block
This gives us the number of barions
That's not what we want, no. So we want to know the number of particles
So we must think about how to distribute those particles
Now, one thing we know is that the universe, on average
Electrically neutral, okay?
Thus, the number of positive points of the stock balances the number of negative charges.
For our purpose, this means that the number of protons will balance the number of electrons
The other part of the information we can use is
We know where these baryons are stored
Well, we know that 75% of them are stored in hydrogen atoms
And 25% in helium atoms. There are other atoms as well, but they are not important
Brady: "Not us"
Yes, not to us, but in the broader scheme of things, it does not matter
By and large, the vast majority of them are up to 75% in hydrogen and 25% in helium
This is where all this is stored
We know that by looking at distant clouds
As we also know from one of the great triumphs of cosmology, nuclear synthesis
So, given this information, suppose we took a sample of four atoms
We know that three of these atoms will become hydrogen, and one of them will become helium, right?
Well, the hydrogen atom consists of a proton and one electron
These three contain three protons and three electrons
The helium atom contains two protons, two neutrons, and two electrons
Thus, now, well, we can divide this, because each of these protons contains three quarks
Each neutron contains three quarks. So exactly how many particles
Which we get from these four atoms? Twenty-six serious
How many barons did we need to get these twenty-six particles?
Well, we have three protons
Two other protons, and two neutrons, and those seven baryons, okay?
So we get twenty-seven of seven bariums
So we know how many barions in total
We know of every seven barions we get twenty-six grams
So if we want the total number of particles
We only need to double this number by twenty-six to seven
So we do just plug in all the numbers
You'll get 3.28 times, then Ramzaleshri, from ten to eighty
This is the number of particles present in the universe
Sounds like many are not you?
Ten to eighty, like this one with eighty zeros, that's a big number, right?
But in fact, the universe is a big place, this is about one particle per cubic meter
It is hardly anything, is it? But of course, as you know, most of the space
Is an empty space
Brady: "This is not one atom per cubic meter, this is one particle"
One particle per cubic meter, yes, exactly
So, the other wonderful thing you think is that you can ask
How many particles are in the normal human body?
Well, we know that the human body contains two-thirds of hydrogen, about a quarter of oxygen
So during all of our information, you can figure out the number of particles
In the human body, about 1.46 times from ten to twenty-nine
Well so they seem to number a lot of particles
But of course not that number in the whole universe, right?
So how many people will they need
To use all particles in the whole universe?
Well, of course, you only take the proportion of those, of these two, right?
So you need 2.25 times ten to one fifty people
To use all particles in the universe
So, there are about 7.5 billion people alive today, are not they?
The current population growth rate is about 1.11 percent annually
So I think it would be interesting to know how long it will take for us
Given this growth rate, for us to use all the particles in the universe, right?
So that we can do so
If we take the population when they use all the particles
This number is divided, so this is the population that corresponds to this number
Divided by the population now
Which is about 7.5 billion
P is now 7.5 times ten to nine
And then this is linked, through exponential
To R growth rate of 1.11 per cent per year
1.11 percent annually
I can plug in all these numbers, and I can rearrange this equation
I get one T on the logarithm P in P length now
So I'm just plugging in the numbers, and it turns out we'll have to exhaust them
Population continues to grow at the same rate
We will consume all particles in the universe
In humans
In the years 8604
Which is not so much
Brady: "I thought it would be ..."
I know, it's amazing. This is exponential
Brady: "We will forget the use of fossil fuels, and we will use all the particles."
We talk about the deep influence on the planet, the effect on the universe, right?
Population growth, that is. In less than ten thousand years
We will use and continue to grow at the same rate
We will consume all the particles of the universe, in the form of humans
Sure, this will happen beforehand, right?
Well, we may have only 8604 years here in the universe
Translation: شوان حميد Twitter: shwan_hamid @